hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren eines der Formate was ihr am
meisten auf meinem Youtube Kanal hier
feiert ist es wenn ich kahoot quizzes
von Fanpages versuche zu lösen von daher
haben sich mal wieder con_loogie logi
der_lotzt und jeweils ein Quiz für mich
erstellt was ich jetzt machen werde ich
tippe alles richtig starten wir mit dem
Quiz für Loser und natürlich sind auch
wieder mal NC Robin und China mit am
Start ich bin gespannt
Frage Nummer eins wie viele Bilder pro
Sekunde sieht das Auge 60
[Musik]
a
60 gibt's hier tatsächlich nicht
deswegen nehme ich mal 25 bis 30
[Musik]
ich sehe safe mehr Frage Nummer zwei wie
viele Schornsteine hatte die Titanic
tatsächlich
nur einer deswegen würde ich sagen 5
[Musik]
stabiles Bild aber auch tatsächlich mal
wieder wie heißt das Internet bei den
Inuits
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
oh mein Gott wenn ich das Blind
beantwortet lange ich Sprachen lernen
Babbel Frage Nummer 4 welchen
Durchmesser haben Bierdeckel im
Durchschnitt boah ich würde sagen eins
zwei drei Zentimeter also
Deckel 81 mm
[Musik]
verdammte
wie lange haben
Stabheuschrecken Sex
[Musik]
Frage Nummer sechs von zehn wie lange
dauert der längste Film der Welt der
längste Film der Welt ach stark ist ich
würde sagen 24 Stunden weil das muss ja
auch alles sehen
ein Monat das ist lustig weil das Quiz
tatsächlich von Mona ist
[Musik]
letzte Frage bei diesem Quiz welches ist
das schottische Nationaltier das weiß
ich das ist ein Biber tatsächlich
wollte ich einmal so tun als ob ich
direkt was kann ist das Alter was ist in
Alaska verboten ich sitze mit einem Bär
in dem Kino weil genau es ist
tatsächlich in Alaska verboten Fische
trinken glaube ich das habe ich schon
ich ja aus dem Flugzeug zu schubsen was
setze Frage bei unserem ersten Quiz was
ist ein Hühnergott
[Musik]
ich
du dummes Kind das ist wahrscheinlich
eine Schallplattenspieler Nadel weil
Hühner
ein Feuerstein mit Loch
also alles andere als der letzte Platz
wird mich wirklich wundern Robin auf dem
dritten nennt sie auf dem zweiten Mal
auf dem ersten und auf dem fünf
dann machen wir weiter mit dem
Gedächtnistest erste von zehn Fragen
welches ist das richtige Logo okay wir
müssen es für Logos miteinander
vergleichen rechts
ich war immer falsch bei Dunkin Donuts
Frage Nummer zwei du hast 20 Sekunden
Zeit um dir die Reihenfolge dieser
emojis zu merken schaffst du das
[Musik]
Haustür klobesen
bucheimer Zahnbürste
und jetzt muss ich das Auflisten oder
was nenne die richtige Reihenfolge der
Wörter okay
[Musik]
weil
da hättest Du so machen müssen das
eigentlich die ersten drei Wörter bei
allen gleich sind weil danach wäre ich
auf jeden Fall schon gestorben gekommen
mit meinem Gehirn ist nicht vorhanden
ist Frage Nummer vier wie viele Leitern
bräuchte man um zum Mond zu kommen
tatsächlich nur eine
ist es im auch guck mal einer an da
vorne das Bild was liegt in der Mitte
von Rom nicht das Kolosseum
[Musik]
ich liebe diese Mischung aus
eigentlich ist keine Mischung ist
einfach nur pure Dummheit welche Zahl
ist auf diesem Bild zu erkennen okay
muss man ganz genau hinschauen
[Musik]
ich habe eine Fünfer Antwort Serie was
ist denn jetzt los ja Leute was geht ich
melde mich hier gerade mal aus dem
Schnitt ist vielleicht bisschen gerade
aber ich wollte nur kurz sagen das ist
genauso wird dass ich das jetzt sage
aber das sieht hier genauso wieder
grasblock in Minecraft
es wird einfach runter
Frage 7 welche Farbe unterscheidet sich
von den anderen
drei
[Musik]
ich bin ein Monsterspieler
gewesen letzte Frage was steht hinter
dem Kölner Dom ein Fragezeichen Sandra
nichts ein Gebäude Fragezeichen
ich kann ich wenig aber solche dummen
Fragen welches Wort kannst du auf diesem
Bild erkennen okay müssen wieder ganz
genau hinschauen
[Musik]
sind meine Augen überdurchschnittlich
gut oder bin ich einfach gut letzte
Frage welche Zahl steht auf dem Bild und
da haben wir eine 378
wir haben einen Neuner Antwort Serie das
hatten wir noch nie ich habe ja
insgesamt schon fünf Mal so kaputt
quizzes von Jessie Malin und Mona
gemacht und das war heute wirklich
Wahnsinn guck mal wie krass das war ich
hatte 9 von 10 richtig
8.589 Punkte was ist los alle bitte mal
König Laser in die Kommentare schreiben
wir jetzt das lasercraft Quiz und dabei
geht es tatsächlich nur um Minecraft
Fragen ihr müsst bedenken ich habe
damals wirklich ein Buch darüber
geschrieben in welcher Jahreszeit blüht
der Krokus
ist keine Minecraft Frage aber der
kokosblüht im Frühling so wie alle
Blumen gefüllt oder im Herbst chillig
bin ich Biologe an der Stelle hier
tatsächlich auch noch mal eine ganz
kurze Meldung aus dem Schnitt ich habe
gerade mal ein bisschen nachgeschaut in
meinem uni-ordner und auch so ein
bisschen recherchiert nee ich bin kein
Biologe zweite Frage wie viele Lukas
kannst du in dem Bild finden das hat
überhaupt nichts mit Minecraft zu tun
das Sirio
1 2 3 4 5
[Musik]
erzählen muss ich glaube ich noch mal
üben wie heißt diese Blume in Minecraft
so aber die Minecraft Fragen das ist
tatsächlich ein sternloch
[Musik]
und damit kenne ich mich wieder aus mit
Minecraft und Lauch was braucht man in
Minecraft um einen Blumentopf zu craften
man braucht Ton also nicht turnblöcke in
die Ziegelsteine dementsprechend weil
man muss ja den Ton erst brennen
drei Luca ergeben einen Lauch wie heißt
dieser Baum oh mein Gott bestimmt eine
Birke damit verwechsel ich immer das ist
tatsächlich ähm eine ist das denn das
ist eine Fichte ne
[Musik]
in Kiefer hat man noch im Gesicht wird
letzte Frage wie viele Minuten braucht
Weizen in Minecraft zum Wachsen boah das
war schon lange ein Minecraft tag 25
Minuten eine Stunde
[Musik]
ich würde sagen ein Minecraft tag
und 30 Minuten wie viele Minuten dauert
ein Tag in Minecraft 8 glaube ich oder
zehn dann halt dementsprechend
oh nein
mein oh nein Minecraft tag also
kompletter Tag und Nacht letzte Frage
war oder falsch Minecraft sollte
ursprünglich Cave Game heißen ist war
aber sollte eigentlich wirklich heißen
hier wohnt Laser Luca
[Musik]
das sieht aus wie Sandras Haus hier bin
ich echt gespannt
[Applaus]
an der Stelle würde ich das heutige
Videos allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben Freunde wenn euch Luca macht
kahoot Quiz ist von Jessi Mali und Mona
gefallen hat dann lass gerne einen
Daumen hoch und ein Video da abonniert
meinen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke
um weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen wie
z.B das hier das ging nämlich gestern
online wenn ihr noch nicht gesehen habt
schaut euch an es war unfassbar witzig
ich habe Sandra die ganze Zeit geprankt
deswegen kriegt er gerne drauf oder
abonniert meinen Kanal könnt ihr hier
auf dem Smiley tun danke noch mal
Jessica am Fanpage das könnt ihr gerne
mal Auschecken ganz ganz verrückten
Humor und sind wahrscheinlich unten in
der Beschreibung